you're a guy in your early 20s
and you're feeling this way alone lonely
loner almost any guy in the early 20s is
going to feel this way have you listen
to a lot of women in their early 20s
they feel this way too I'm never going
to find the right guy all the same thing
what you're talking about in in the
reverse for women great many women
feeling that way focus on the parts that
you can control uh the parts that you
can't you know you you can't you can't
make
um the perfect woman materialize at a
thinner you can't do that you can't
control other people if you meet a woman
and she's not the right the right kind
of woman you can't make her into that
and you probably you shouldn't try you
know you can't make a woman into the
kind of woman who you want to marry but
you can make yourself into the kind of
man that women want to marry